there's a dangerous new weapon on the
streets it's scaring police officers
across the country more and more people
are carrying it as it becomes cheaper
and more available every day that weapon
is the camera
the laws surrounding public photography
and the recording of police encounters
are vague and complicated subject to
variance from one local jurisdiction to
the next software developer and
libertarian blogger Antonio Moussa Mechi
found himself in the midst of this legal
fog in late 2009 I had come across a
story randomly about this fellow named
Julian hi :
77 or 78 year old at the time who was
doing jury nullification outreach in
Manhattan not far from where I work hi
Clint is a legal activist known for
passing out jury nullification
literature outside of courthouses and
often getting arrested for doing so in
his particular style of passive
resistance
antonio met up with hi clan at the
daniel patrick moynihan United States
courthouse the federal courthouse Julian
has selected for the day's protest
Monday November the 9th at 11:30 I get
there a little earlier than he was
planning to be there I had a little spy
cam on my on my belt and I had a cannon
fs100 flash camera it's about the size
of soda can eventually he showed up and
almost instantly - I suspect court
officers showed up and looked like they
were giving him some grief
stand here can I
just seeing what's happening they tell
me can't be there he disagrees clifford
barn then shows up the arresting officer
and the jurisdictions of which I'm aware
there's no prohibition on video
recording or photographing things when
you're standing in a public place and
you're looking and add another public
place Eugene Bullock a law professor at
UCLA who runs the popular law blog the
valk conspiracy explains that citizen
ignorance of the law sometimes allows
police to get away with more than they
otherwise would not everybody knows what
the law is and sometimes not even old
police officers know what the law is not
film the building why is it illegal is
there a law so there sometimes are myths
that spring up about how this is
supposedly illegal that supposedly
illegal 12 states have laws banning the
audio recording of conversations in
which both parties have not consented
this is how many cases involving filmed
police encounters are prosecuted my
civil liberties are being violated at
this moment quite a videotape but as it
happens the unfortunate reality is that
often police officers can intimidate
people into and not doing things they
otherwise legally could officers
employed intimidation tactics against
moose amici as they arrested protestor
Julian hi :
News Agency okay mister your ID
absolutely you do I'm a listener of free
talk live it's a libertarian radio show
out of New Hampshire the people who run
the show often say well if you're
approached by a cop and they ask like
why are you there why you filming you
know tell them you're a producer for
free talk live because anyone can call
up the show and provide news well I did
that and they assumed that it was
commercial and so he instantly arrested
me without warning
officers actually arrested and charged
Moussa Mechi for a federal code
prohibiting commercial photography of a
federal building they seized one of his
cameras and issued a $75 citation Musa
Messi brought the case to the NY CLU we
have long been involved with helping
people who have been harassed by law
enforcement officers while engaging in
photography mr. Musa met she was at
federal court and he had problems with
federal officials and since 9/11 we had
been concerned about and have received
reports about harassment by federal
officers at federal buildings here in
New York City so this was an opportunity
to pursue that the NY CLU filed suit
Unruh Symmetry's behalf the government
almost immediately recognized that what
they had done was improper or that the
rule they were enforcing could not be
enforced against photographers on public
property outside of federal buildings
and consequently very quickly agreed to
a settlement in which they would
recognize as they have done that this
sort of photography is completely lawful
there's no prohibition against it the
government agreed in the settlement in
this case to send written directive to
all Federal Protective Service officers
informing them that there was no
prohibition against photography from
public property of federal courthouses
and the rule is very clear people can
engage in public photography of federal
buildings while the issue of filming on
federal property may be closer to
resolution the question of recording
encounters with police is still an open
one here's what photographers should
keep in mind it's legal to film federal
buildings in public spaces know your
local wiretapping laws before filming
ask which ordinance is being enforced if
challenged by law enforcement
but unless federal courts make a ruling
the law will remain necessarily murky
explains bollock First Amendment applies
to all states and to the federal
government but the Supreme Court has
never made it quite clear what the rules
are with regard to news gathering under
the First Amendment and in a new media
world where every blogger with a cell
phone camera is a potential journalist
the umbrella of news gathering
protection may need to be quite large
turn that goddamn thing off and get out
of here no one could imagine a pretty
aggressive view
newsgathering rights which is that if
you're in a in a public place if you're
not trespassing on private property
you're entitled to gather information
because how can you effectively speak if
you can't gather the information
necessary for you to speak a lot of
these laws were written with an eye
towards protecting privacy even when
they involve communications that really
have little to do with privacy as we
generally understand the term as most of
us understand it well the laws about
recording encounters with public
officials remain vague musa Mechi and
many others will have to continue
risking arrest to test the boundaries of
free speech and unfortunately law
enforcement officials have confused
public photography with dissent or
espionage or criminal activity and
that's just wrong when you're talking
about police officer interactions
citizens by and large there's there's a
lot of benefit to to having them be
recorded and then be monitored most
government action ends up being better
done when it is done in public there's
nothing better than being able to you
know provide objective reality you know
this film footage and then just putting
your little spin on it and it'll say
well you know make your own decision
that there's just nothing the government
can do about it without outright banning
you know cell phone cameras for reason
TV I'm Hawk Jensen
you